so my name is nick guys nick bartle and
i am the digital marketing trainer
working with simply learn for
almost an year
and it's been quite a wonderful journey
by i do deliver a lot of corporate
trainings and a lot of uh digital
marketing certified associate training
for this particular
for the dmc course and so forth
so the topic for today's
webinar is the trick to affiliate
marketing so i'm not going to get
started by introducing and telling what
exactly affiliate marketing is and
what exactly is being done in this what
is the process and so forth the topic is
about the tricks
right the
major
ways through which you can get across
results in a much quicker fashion and
these smart techniques i would say
that's what i'm going to be talking
about before i get started with our
topic for today i just want to go ahead
and give you across a small brief
introduction about myself wherever you
will have any questions or any doubt
please feel free to use across the
question and answer panel which you can
see in the go to webinar uh
dashboard all right
okay so that's me guys
my name is nick
and uh
i i basically come from uh toronto
canada i'm a digital marketing
enthusiast and a professional it's been
more than 18 years i've been into this
profession
and when it comes down to training i've
trained more than 5000 professionals
including uh you know various other
organizations where i have conducted
digital marketing trainings and so forth
and if i talk about the digital
marketing services being offered in my
entire career i've
helped more than 1200 clients of our
different
sizes different business sizes whether
it's a small medium or the fortune 500
organizations have helped them in
optimizing their websites running their
social media campaign running their paid
media campaign and so forth various
activities now this has been and i've
worked for myself or when i have worked
with various different agencies and the
kind of fortune 500 trends if i talk
about i have handled campaign for
companies like pepsi
citibank ebay and several others
now when it comes down to certifications
guys i've made myself eligible for all
the possible certifications in this
industry in this industry i'm a google
adwords analytics e-commerce mobile
digital analytics e-commerce and several
others so bring hubspot youtube several
other certifications have been so i keep
get uh renewing them over the period of
time
in terms of experience like i told you
it's more than 18 years i've been into
this industry it was i started my career
in digital marketing
in the year 1998 and that was the year
when google also came into existence in
terms of my education i am a masters in
business administration from university
of toronto canada
along with training guys i have a
full-time goal to take care of i have my
own agency internet marketing agency
which is based out of toronto canada
again
and it's by the name of your creation
center so we do cater across to all our
clients across the globe and provide
them internet marketing services like
again facebook marketing linkedin
marketing
youtube
search engine optimization google
adwords banner ads and so forth and
affiliate marketing several others in
case you want to know more about us you
can refer to our website which is your
creations dot ca
i i'm also speaking at several other
course colleges and universities some of
those being university of toronto humber
college toronto uh iim and above i i am
bangalore
uh iit kharagpur and several others so
these are some of the colleges and
universities where i do speak on digital
marketing on regular basis
all right so in case you want to know
more about me uh the more my detailed
profile you can always go to
linkedin.com and check in my profile
in terms of my clientele to uh my
corporate clienteles from the training
perspective here are the some of the
names hsbc penguin publication fidelity
and several other organizations where i
keep delivering
trainings to their
entire digital marketing team and so
forth also i'm uh
i i work with godaddy with google
microsoft along with market model and
simply learn as a trainer so i do
deliver trainings for them also on a
regular basis i'm on the panel as a
trainer all right so that's a small
brief about me we're going to get
started now and talk about the affiliate
marketing tips and tricks that actually
work okay
so i hope all of you are aware about
what exactly affiliate marketing is it
is uh all about going ahead and
promoting someone else's product and
getting an affiliate commission by
selling their product onto your panel or
by just getting across an affiliate link
whatever the way you want to do it
either you have your own website and on
your website you go ahead and place
across the
products of someone else all right the
advertiser who wants to sell their
product and if you are able to sell
their product through your affiliate id
or through your website then you get a
certain commission out of the entire
sales amount it's purely based uh it's a
performance based model
i would
like to
emphasize on one thing that many people
talk about affiliate marketing as a
quick uh
rich
kind of a stream people feel that you
know you work less and you become rich
by without making a lot of effort with
affiliate marketing but that's very rare
in a very
rare kind of situations in a very
selective situation that has happened
across it is a lot of effort as well
needed in this particular piece of work
in order to make much more money so
there is nothing of that so i want to
break that
specific uh
you know notion which many people have
got about every apa
so i'm going to talk one by one i've got
17 different tricks which we as
affiliate marketers we are affiliate
marketers i'm assuming uh all those who
are attending the session they know
about affiliate marketing and they are
doing it they have run across affiliate
marketing campaigns and uh this so they
need more tricks they need more so
that's one assumption guys which i'm
already taking since the topic is about
the tricks right
so i've got 17 tips and tricks to talk
about
in order to get across better results
for affiliate marketing number one is
the uh own your audience now what
exactly it really means is
if you have got an affiliate website of
yours if you've got a website of yours
where you're putting across affiliate
products from
various other different websites
make sure you're not just going ahead
and trying to look for
selling of those products it's also
about maintaining good relation with
your audience
right it's not just a momentary or a
temporary thing that you are looking at
selling across products to and to a
certain set of people it's all about
maintaining good relation
so earlier what people used to do they
used to have bridge pages uh which were
used in order to get across affiliate
marketing being done for them but that's
not a
effective long-term affiliate marketing
uh thing
in order to have a long-term affiliate
marketing thing it's all about owning
the audience
and
the thing which i told you which is
bridge pages which is not recommended
they do not really value any
uh they do not provide any value to the
surface it's absolutely bad for the
customers and bad for the entire
business at all
you're just one step from the google
hammer it's very unstable it's hosted on
third-party platforms these blitz pages
so i'm not going to teach you what
bridge pages are and so forth since it's
a
a sort of a
negative thing to do across plus these
bridge pages and so forth if you're not
owning your audience you do not have
even a recall value amongst your
audience there's no customer recall
value why would someone come back to you
or why would someone refer you it's
going to be a lot of effort which you
have to put in plus you have to always
generate fresh traffic every day it's
like you were working every day working
hard to get across new set of people
again and again and again but you're not
maintaining good relationship with your
existing audience
so an audience you have direct access to
is called own audience so what exactly
happens on your website when you are
specifically providing across a place
for your audience to come over and
subscribe to your email list and put it
across their
details so that you can be in touch with
them that's the best way
best way to do that
so
many people go ahead and stop by our
website
and
if they find it interesting they're your
brand your entire website they'll keep
coming back again and
you can also contact them since they
have opted in by providing their email
address
now these are the two characteristics
that define the owned audience number
one is the trust your readers when they
have a relationship with you they see
and you they see your website as an
authoritative figure in your field you
know they try to so you become the
influencer you tried you try to actually
let your audience know
that you are the masters in this you
have you've got all the skill sets and
that's why you're giving us a lot of
information about certain things no
matter whatever that particular website
would be it always translates into
higher trust and number second
characteristics that defines the old
audience is the direct access to your
readers you can
communicate to them at any given point
of time by sending them an email by
creating a video and circulating that
video across amongst your audience or
making them
follow
follow your twitter profile and sharing
first tweets with them and so forth so
no matter if there are any google
algorithm changes or facebook facebook
algorithm changes still you have the
email addresses to reach out to your own
audience pretty easily all right so you
must own your audience what exactly is
the reason we had that it is much more
stable since you do not really rely on
the single channel for your traffic you
are distributing that across amongst
various topics and plus you are this way
able to make much more sales you know
unlike bridge page you can
you can reach out to an audience
anytime
you have a new whenever you put across
any new post and in your tweet and so
forth if you have any let's say a
product demo product launch
or a promotion going on
plus it's good for the future product
owners too and so
building across your audience from the
scratch you are
going ahead and adding more and more to
your existing audience list right it's a
ready-made platform in order to
transition to a product owner
so how do you really own your audience
by building an email list or also by
growing your social profile by having a
fan base but making the engagement thing
happening across and also
one of the greatest ways to grow your
retargeting list now i'm assuming again
that you guys are already into internet
marketing and you understand what
retargeting is all about if you're in if
you are already doing affiliate
marketing
all right number two trick is to always
have a backup offer so with affiliate
marketing you as an affiliate always
look for offers to promote across and
earn your affiliate commission out of it
by selling that offer so do not just
look up one uh so it's very much like
you know do not put all your eggs in one
basket so that's what this second trick
is all about it's it's like always have
multiple offers to promote across your
best performing affiliate offer gets
pulled over from the market let's say
so in these scenarios you should have a
backup offer there can be any many other
things that can kill a successful
marketing campaign like a product owner
changes the payment terms or your
conversion rate drops or your good cdr
goes down in these kind of scenarios in
these kind of scenarios you should
always have a backup offer other backup
other offer to really rely on
now having a backup offer have three key
benefits here are the benefits it gives
you an insurance
in case your primary offer fails to
charges
changes it's for it changes its term you
have a ready alternative as insurance
right plus you get
more sales you can offer alternatives
and reach a larger audience if someone
has already bought
an existing offer you can of in interest
them in another second offer or a third
offer and so forth plus it also leads to
better conversion rates you can test
multiple offers against each other to
see what converts
the best
the number three third point
the number third trick i would rather
say in the affiliate marketing is to
track your links now what do we really
mean by track your legs guys
it's all about going ahead and seeing
which all links have really resulted
into sales for you if you do not know
where your sale is coming from then you
have uh you have a better shape up your
campaigns perfectly all right so
tracking link helps you to know which
specific keywords have converted the
best so that you can put in more money
for into those keywords you need to
track what pages brings in the most
revenues you can so that you can create
more
many more pages like those
you should analyze which marketing
channels has delivered the best return
on marketing investment or return on
investment so this way you're going to
shift across the marketing budgets from
the non-performing marketing channels to
the performing ones plus you should you
would be able to detect whether any
fraud affiliate companies are using your
traffic without
crediting you with the sales right so
simply put affiliate marketing without
link tracking is like shooting dots
from 200 feet while blindfolded and
spinning in circles so do not get into a
situation where you're not tracking
further link that's very essential
number fourth trick
for affiliate marketing is use
retargeting guys i hope most of you are
already aware about it it's all about
whenever somebody comes onto your
website and leaves a website without
buying a product let's say by abandoning
the shopping cart due to any other any
further reason wants to decide wants to
take more time and so forth in that case
retargeting is being done in order to
show the same product to those set of
audience who have visited your website
so in sales and marketing it's very well
known the rule of seven what rule of
seven says that you need at least seven
touch points
with your prospect before you can turn
your
customer before you can turn that
prospect sorry into a paying customer
so if a prospect comes to you you need
to have on an average
seven touch points with that prospect in
order to convert them right and that has
to already add on all the touch points
are going to be assisted so remarketing
really works well in that center in that
scenario right so it's a process of
showing you your ads to people who have
already visited your website but haven't
completed a transaction yet
all right so it's a massive opportunity
to increase sales by targeting people
engaged with before
retargeting offers a various other
number of benefits if number one is the
conversion rates it's been seen that
more than 65 percent of the uh
people who see the banner at the game
who have visited your website they get
converted across so in the that's for
the e-commerce in certain
in certain uh
researchers it has been observed and
like i said it reaches out audience have
already interacted and it gives you
better conversion rates so there's
already slightly familiar they know your
brand they have gathered more
information about your brand it's just
that they need more push
right and that can be that is
done perfectly by retargeting
it also offers you the opportunity to
run learn across or sorry to offer
earn across better higher return on the
spin usually one semester has left your
site you have to go through the same
entire acquisition process to attract
them again right so whether to
put it across
a google ad again
or to get across a new podcast or a new
blog post or and so forth so retargeting
cuts down on the entire time of going
ahead and following that same procedure
again it also cuts down on the cost
spent in this process by reaching the
visitors which have been lost right
directly so you get much better roi with
this
the other benefit of retargeting guys is
the
sales increase right that's what we as
affiliates are really looking for we
always get paid across for the sales
which we are able to make right so
retargeting allows you to reach your
target audience at scale with better
conversion rates lower cost this
translates into increased sales and
better revenues
for you
now after number four the fifth
one guys the fifth trick is to use lead
magnets to segment your audience it's
all about segmenting your audience
so with your different web pages on your
website
you need to have
different
email lists being created so that you
offer
right product right promotional offer
you put push across to try to a certain
set of people you do not mix and match
so your audience is quite complex right
emotional scenarios different visitors
to your site have different interests in
different things
one might be let's say a blogger
who's hoping to learn how to write his
first blog post i'll give an example and
let's say the other one might be a
seasoned marketer looking for a new
email marketing strategies so they both
are different so how do you understand
this audience and give it what it wants
this is only about segmenting the
audience with the lead magnets so lead
magnets work work they work wonderfully
for
well for capturing emails but they're
also very useful for dividing your
audience into different interest group
and then pushing across
emailers pushing them pushing across
more messages to the right of people
with the right content
the number six is after segmentation of
your audience is to link
relevant offers on thank you pages now
this is something which very less
affiliate marketers do
it's all about
exciting the existing customer who have
bought from you for another product so
if somebody has bought a product a
product a and then they have done the
payment and then they go on to the thank
you payment page in thank you page go
ahead and offer them across another
another
another product which can be of similar
nature which uh might complement the
existing product that's been sold across
and so forth
so this one is pretty simple
and many people skip it like i said
think about it
these steps as a prospect might must
take to get to the thank you page
so
let's say for an example entering across
the email into the opt-in box click on
the confirm email address download the
lead magnet or and then reach the thank
you page
so that's three actions that uh that's
there just to get in get onto this page
the leads are very warm at that point of
time they have already
uh you know
got confidence in your brand and they
have went ahead and made a payment and
they are bought in across a product so
they've already given you their emails
but they already have good impression of
you why not go ahead and take a cost
benefit of that thing then and there
this makes it a perfect time
to push and offer their way all right
now there is a warning guys
don't be too aggressive with this
strategy don't push too many products
and never sell a non-relevant product
also it has to be very much relevant if
it's not relevant and you're being pushy
then it might work the other way readers
should not have to go through the hoops
just to exit your page they should not
have it
the seventh
trick guys to affiliate marketing is to
follow up more than once
about the targeted products this is
something which very less affiliate
marketers again
do it and most of them most of the
affiliate marketers don't do it
what happens is
that
two percent of the sales it's been seen
that only two percent of the sales
happen on the very first try
you cannot
really expect
to come on somebody to come on your
website and then buy it across the very
first stage and they will obviously they
will most of the times the majority of
the audience will take
much more time and like i said as for
the studies it's only two percent of
sales that happen on the first try this
mean 98 of the prospects don't buy
without multiple prior guys they want to
test field uh try you want to take
demonstration they want to take the
reviews and so forth 30 percent of the
sales require at least five follow-ups
all that branding stuff and uh taking
reviews is absolutely there but as a
marketer it's our job to actually do
much more follow-ups but that too in a
subtle fashion it should not found it
should not sound like you're being way
too pushy about it right
this is basically for the seasoned sales
people
who are selling highly rated products
from well-known companies
what chance does an affiliate marketer
have to sell a product on the first try
this is exactly what so many marketers
do they send out an email
it's very less that it gets sold across
for the very first time
it's important to get both half of these
tactics right right so follow more than
once and fix the targeted products
the number eight
number eight trick guys
is to show your face and personality
now in your website
if you're just going ahead and putting
across a lot of content and so forth
then things might not really rotate and
revolve across the way it can with the
help of a specific human face added onto
it you might have seen many people who
have got their own personal brand and
they add on to their website they get
across much more benefit because people
trust
trust the face of the person the entire
profile rather than the
brand of the website so brand of the
website also can be graded across but
that takes a lot of time it's the human
face which goes and gels well with the
entire thing pretty easily it's very
clear successful
bloggers i'm sorry successful bloggers
don't hide behind behind anonymity
their blogs always have a face
others have a face and a personality to
go with it
this is true not just for blogging but
for the other uh but for other affiliate
marketing as a whole
where once fake identities and generic
web pages were common real faces and
personalities now dominate across
all right so always show across your
face and personality people remember
faces more than the names
and that will also help you to stand out
from the crowd a real face and
personality helps you stand out from the
no name competitors in the search engine
results pages plus it will also help you
with google human writers who are
trained to look out for trustworthiness
expertise and authoritativeness
also
the other benefit is that it help
readers relate to you a real personality
help readers identify with you
marketers should use pictures of people
and headshots in particular
real photographs should be used across
for building credibility and pictures of
people increase across the conversion
rate so that's the reason why one should
add across face and personality to it
but having more pictures by more having
more videos as well added on to your
marketing stuff
number nine trick is to show real world
use of product
so your readers today
are skeptical you know they have seen
far too many spammy marketers
recommending product a product b this
product that product without ever
actually using them these marketers are
actually promoting them and that is
absolutely not a good thing to do if you
are sending across something you should
have the belief
in those products and it should be used
across by you as affiliate marketers
also
so their trust question
in product reviews and comparison has
taken a beating for for all the
customers this is when you can
when when you can show the real world
use a product you will instantly stand
out from the competition and that's what
you really want if you can stand out
from the competition you can achieve
much more sales you can take that
markets here there has been a lot of
research on this project on the subject
and according to
cmo real world user generated images of
products can boost conversion rates
and so forth
so there are three reasons why real
world products use works it increases
that trust right readers are more likely
to trust an author if they know that he
she actually bought the you what and use
that right so marketer also need to be
using those products on their regular
intervals and need to show that this is
what
was the before
buying for before
buying product stage and after the
product has been bought and has been
used what's the situation right now
right what all benefits did you as a
product user
made out of it
the other one is shows context if you're
talking about physical products real
images can show the product in actual
use so this provides powerful context to
readers which can improve conversion
rates and the other one is to help it
helps you to create better
content if you don't actually want to
product you have to either lie or find
complex workarounds to talk about the
product so this affects the quality of
the content you can create screenshots
videos walkthroughs webinars all high
converted content types are essentially
closed off
now the tenth one guys
is to focus on benefits and not the
features
now what do you read what do we really
okay so i have a question right now
which is from anub what does a crp stand
for short sarp stands for search engine
results page all right let me just show
you what exactly crp is so if i go on to
google
and i type in across any specific
keyword
all right
now here are these search results if i
scroll further down now this is s e r p
one search engine result page one where
all these results are there and then
this is a crp two
and then three and then four and so
forth so this is one page search engine
results page all right hope it makes
sense
search engine results page
let me know if you've got the answer for
your question
all right it's my pleasure
so the 10th point guys is
bridging across
features and the benefits now if you are
content marketers if anybody of you is a
content marketer who
writes quite a lot on
daily basis
then uh
or not on a daily basis maybe on a
regular basis i would say and you must
have heard that it's more about
focusing on the benefits of the product
in the content and rather than not
rather than on the features the features
might be
teachers reaches are
in most of the scenarios not at all
uh
attractive enough to the end audience
the end audience find the benefits to be
much more attractive
so let's say think about the last ebook
guys which you have bought did you buy
that ebook but just because it had 100
plus pages pages it had a nice
you know glossy design you know cover
the page material or was it just because
it had a better design
and a well-made sales page
also
or did you buy it because it sold a real
problem for most of us
the ladder path it falls through which
is that it solved a real problem
right so benefits what a product does is
the reason why people buy things
features are nice to have but are
redundant unless they solve an actual
problem so wherever there is a problem
the market is finds an opportunity in it
so that's where the benefits should be
posted across
and these benefits should tie up very
well with the problem which is there
let's take an ad example of apple guys
what exactly apple does
every product apple sells across it
focuses on
on the benefits from owning an apple
product you know apple seldom focuses
across on various features like these
many gb or mb of ram which is the
processor which we offer across no
apple doesn't do it
and when it does it's only to highlight
those features that help solve problems
so this is the way macbook
overall benefits have been displayed
across rather than the features of it so
it breaks the features and benefits like
i said so take a take a look at the page
of the apple's new book macbook
it says 13.1 mm
two pounds live 12 inches red to my
display and so
forth now at the very top apple
highlights a macbook's lightweight and
ears ahead design it then backs up this
benefit by mentioning the features that
makes this possible like 13.1 millimeter
thin profile two pounds lower weight so
that's been backed up later on but
initially it's the benefits that all
with a 12-inch retinal display so in
marketing however too many marketers
focus on the features of a product they
talk about the
all the cool tricks their product has
the hours they have spent in developing
it and on a long pre-page manual you
might guys have seen that that is
something which is not recommended
nobody is interested in
knowing all that stuff uh you know which
is there in that page manual and so
forth so your customers don't care
care about any of those all they want to
know is
how those 200 plus pages will solve
their problem so you just have to really
focus across on the problem and that if
you can do that across for the help of
your fda website and let people know
about that you're you can absolutely go
ahead and get more traffic on your
website and get much more
uh you know sales for your recreate
products
so that's what i have to say guys
whenever you have any questions like i
said feel free to put that across in the
chat window
or the question answer panel so that i
can answer that
that's number 10 over here what you can
see this is the difference between
features and benefits guys
features focus on the tech so features
are the ones which focus on the
technical specs
it appeals to the logic and it competes
on the matrices like price number of
features etcetera and if we talk about
the benefits
benefits focus on solving the problems
it appealed to the emotions and they
compete on utility and how
it makes you feel
so here's what you need to do when you
talk about your products guys
on a blank sheet of paper you can list
all your product features
and next to each feature list the
problem it solves the cost right
bridge this
feature benefit gap by taking about
talking about a benefit you know and
focusing on how specific feature helps
you realize the benefit across
that's the best exercise to do
when we are implementing this trip this
tip and the trick for affiliate
marketing
the number eleventh tip and the trick
for affiliate marketing guys is to add
some salt in the woods now it might
sound my
bit awkward but that's that's what it is
so based on about what we are we can say
that people buy products because the
problem they have but that's what we
have discussed
but it's not nearly enough to solve
problems it's also crucial to sell
people the solution to the problem right
knowing the problems is not enough it's
also about
selling the solution to the problem you
have seen this tactic at a plane
everything
in everything from information to ebooks
sales pages they focus on on your
problems amplify them and then they come
up with a solution
in the book
all right so this book keep it simple
selling
the author of that says that every sales
relationship is defined by two piece
guys problems and possibilities and
possible problems are definitely an
opportunity
for the marketers to really
uh get across
attention of various different customers
now the 12th one and a very exciting one
guys which is a very creative one which
i would say all of you would agree there
oh
you would agree that the usage of
internet guys have changed totally
i mean uh people are accessing internet
using across internet uh more on mobile
phones rather than on desktops and
laptops number one plus the kind of
content consumption which people are
doing it is moving
way too much from the text can text
contain
to images or from images to the video
content right the animated stuff the
moving content
if i ask you what is the second largest
search engine in the world guys which
one is it is it bing or is it yahoo or
ask
so
let me ask you this i have a question
for each one of you the first
largest search engine is google we all
know that which is the second one is it
bing or yahoo or ask.com guys
what are these
so
i've got three options for you
bing yahoo and asks.palm
which is the second
largest search engine
in the world
so you can use across the chat panel or
the question answer panel to go ahead
and answer it across your answer across
this question and the question is what
is the second largest search engine in
the world
is it a bing or is it b yahoo or is it c
ask.com or it's a sort of say ask
anybody else thanks sorry for answering
anybody else else who wants to
put it across an answer to this praveen
or anu
okay
well great try thank you so much sarah
well none of the above is the right
answer
the second largest search engine after
google it's youtube actually
and
that's you know view video in itself has
already power in it just because of the
kind of content
video is and the second thing is
it is the second most populated and the
most visited search engine
youtube.com every month millions of
people type billions of queries into
youtube search box and this search for
various things like music videos for
screencasts for reviews of new products
and so forth so
all this has helped youtube become the
third most heavily trafficked website in
the world as well behind
only google and facebook
all right so that's point number two
[Music]
and uh tip and the trick number 13 guys
is to offer across offered to answer
questions now this is all about like i
said owning the audience it's all about
engaging as well
you go ahead and meet across more people
on the internet also
and this is all about
answering people's question if you know
the answer to those right there are many
websites like quora.com yahooanswers.com
where people are seeking in help from
other people's experience so if you can
help them
and uh this will really build in your
credibility for your affiliate website
so there hasn't been there hasn't been a
better time to ask and to answer
questions so from quora.com reddit.com
there are countless platforms that are
that have opportunities for you to
answer questions
three things happen when you do this
activity you are first of all
establishing across your authority in
most people's mind if you have an answer
to a question
you must be an authority in your field
all right
so that's one thing and if you you gain
search engine visibility also along with
this specific task
so when you answer a question you have a
higher likelihood of showing up in the
search engine result pages for those for
the related searches here in the crps i
told you just now what exactly scrps are
plus you are establishing trust when
people see questions
then the questions being
answered
they trust your expertise more
this trust translates into more sales
all right
so there are a number of platforms where
you can answer across questions guys you
can offer detailed answer on your own
website or blog also
plus you can create a video or to answer
across
someone's question and share it across
on uh youtube that's another great way
tons of people will look for how to's
and youtube video and youtube will
gladly pipe
through your link right but say look at
your video they'll buy
really answer questions in your niche in
quora right to get started and to learn
what a helpful quora answer looks like
and so forth you can start a short daily
weekly podcast answering or reading
questions you can respond to comments on
several other people's blog and other
blogs
and so forth
now the
trip
the tip
and the trick number 14 to affiliate
marketing guys
i would like to repeat that again if you
have any question with regards to
whatever you have covered so far
feel free to put that across in the chat
windows or the question answer panel so
that i can go ahead and answer that
so number 14 guys is offering
alternatives i did tell you having
backup is a good technique
right so that if one of your offer which
is doing well you do not really rely on
that
you need to have a backup similarly
it's on the same line that
you should have alternatives always
go ahead and promote across multiple
products rather than just promoting plus
one product
this is
for the reason that people might
uh think that you're being biased
towards a product right
a lot of your users will question your
motivations on promoting across a single
product on your site they might think
that you have certain extra interest
monetary and interest and so forth or
maybe you've been paid by the product
like i said so there's a simple way out
of this
conundrum offer multiple
alternatives to a product
right so this has four different
benefits
all right
so i have a question uh from praveen
says should we promote through website a
blog which one is better for affiliate
marketing well if you ask me
a website with a blog embedded into it
so proper website with a specific
another url or section in the blog so
your section in the website which is the
blog section
so both are important for me but website
being the primary one and within the
website you have the blog in it
right whether it's a personal blog or a
corporate blog you can go ahead and
decide that across as for your business
understand it
makes sense so it's all so in short the
answer to your question is
having a website
with a blog embedded into it
as one of the
other
element or one of the other
portion
of your website
so here are the four distinct benefits
of having across
operating across alternatives it shows
you that you're not partial to any
products and that you are only
recommending
one because of its superior quality
my pleasure for me
the other one is that it shows you that
you have
that you have the users best interest in
mind you care about them and getting the
highest quality product in or to them
not the product that
gives you much higher commissions right
the other one other benefit of having
alternative is that it increases your
sales you can add affiliate links to the
alternative products as well people
won't people who wouldn't have bought
your initial offering might buy the
alternatives right
and the other other benefit of having
alternative
of of offering alternatives is that it
improves the conversion rate offering
alternative changes the question
in the buyer's mind from where should i
buy this which of these should i buy is
a powerful sales psychology tactic that
can be dramatically improved conversion
rates and so
forth right so hanukkah says
how we can do uh marketing of a seminar
together audience
all right so marketing of a seminar is
even marketing which you can use it
across you can provide it across with
the help of paid ads
that's the best one and totally depends
upon your end audience i know
your seminar is going to be attended
across by what's on what kind of people
and what are their online browsing
behavior which website do they move
you know uh go across the most so as for
your
end audience browsing behavior
that has to it has to be marketed across
that way
but
more more or less it has to be the paid
ads
in many scenarios the event-based
marketing is purely the paid marketing
because the time frame is less you don't
get a lot of time that which you can
which allows you to get across
optimization being done across and so
forth right that's the most uh
patience level game but with
with a seminar you won't get a lot of
time to get your website on to the top
organically right
now the 15th point guys the 15th
tip and the trick to affiliate marketing
is to offer bonuses
now how so all right my pleasure i knew
now as
offering bonuses what exactly it means
that
if you are promoting across one single
product or right of an advertiser
the different other affiliates who are
competing with you will also be
providing same product with same
everything like the pricing and all that
right so how can you really so in that
kind of a situation when you have
a competition how can you really
convince a buyer to purchase a product
from your
or from you over others so it is by
giving them across more motivations more
incentives or more bonuses whatever you
want to call them
bonus is essentially an incentive like
authority related to the affiliate
product it can be anything for let's say
an additional ebook or an industry video
or an additional a checklist document or
a tutorial right totally depends upon
what sort of
product it is and what's your indulgence
is right so as long as it's
illegal
you know
you're not supposed to pay for people
for buying
from your link and so forth right that's
not recommended so it's important
however to create the
right bonuses to maximum affiliate
income
so sell the product and give away the
bonuses for free and you do not sell the
product and bonuses as a practice price
now the 16th point guys the second last
tip and the trick is to get special
deals and add scarcity
all those who are uh here from
india guys you must must have seen this
is very much done by the
brand uh
maruti so maruti cars
they always go ahead and create across
the scarcity and then they bring it
across the specialties also
whether they do it offline but they're
following the same procedure
marketing efforts and that too very
badly right
so now we know that customers are lazy
and even if they are a hundred percent
sure that they want to buy a product
they'll put it off for tomorrow they'll
keep procrastinating with us and that's
that's absolutely true
in today's world so
how can you really convince them to buy
from you today instead of buying from
someone else tomorrow by offering them a
special deal that comes with a deadline
also you've already seen this
tactic used in physical stores and
e-commerce sites right groupon etc
for example sales product had a discount
then throws in the deadline to
compel action
all right so what you can see over here
this is a special deal being offered
across
and that too for a limited time period
right this is the special day
that's the price
this is the deadline and so forth
and uh
also it shows the scarcity part with the
social food and so forth
now whenever you put across a deadline
for a specific thing
always honor that lots of marketers say
that they will
they will close an offer after a few
hours but never actually would do so
this will affect
your reputation and make people distrust
any future deals with you you might have
right so that's with special offers guys
just a second
now the last one guys the last trick
to affiliate marketing i bought 17 in
total
the last trick is to
save you to give across discounts and
save them across for the exit pod
all right so the purpose of discount is
pretty simple to convert the hesitant
visitors into buyers
if however you offer discounts right off
the bat you will lose the money by
giving discounts to people who
would have
what even in the full price right and
then you're offering them discount
this is why you must have your discounts
must save your discounts for the exit uh
this way
those who are hesitating to buy
because the price have a better chance
to convert
right
so i hope it's all clear guys so
this is an example of how the e-commerce
website is giving across a discount
for exit
all right so praveen says any suggestion
which products we can go for affiliate
marketing and initial status well books
are good they're the most
hot selling products books
electronics also because these are the
products which get sold across on the
internet space pretty easy and people
are not so
above even
the gadgets it's the
books the paper the hardcore books
i would say right so that would be the
best because they are the ones which
started with amazon also started with
that and many more people who are into
uh you know reading
they
they're very much
buy it across from
internet and so forth all right so
that's number
so
every digital marketer
should be
knowing across all the different aspects
of
should be doing all the different
aspects of digital marketing and so
forth so this is the screen graph of our
dmc course which is digital marketing
certified as sale of course you can go
into this
page and get across
a lot of information about
your digital marketing and so forth
all right so
we're on the word
wrapping up the session guys any
specific questions uh feel free to put
that across in the chat window so i can
go ahead and answer that across
all right so any questions guys before
we wrap up our session for today are we
doing good
and up in ravine
and ravine says
thanks nick nice seminar my pleasure
ravi
really appreciate it
are you good i knew anything from your
side
any questions guys
before we wrap up our session for today
and
all right my pleasure and look and uh
praveen you say what
here have to take i'm sorry i i can give
you a question
if you can let me know
maybe by typing in again
thank you so much anub
uh for appreciating for us and
thanks to you guys as well for being
interactive
very appreciate that
all right so praveen says any risk is
there from our side
so risk for what purpose
for the affiliate marketing are you
talking about in totality or what uh
what part
this is for the
okay for me this is my bad service from
manufacturer
i'm seriously okay not able to
understand uh
uh proven your question what exactly it
is
you know this shall we uh then wrap up
the session or any further questions
guys
all right so who says
what are the best key points we have to
take care while marketing a cell seminar
well
the best key points is the ad copy which
you will be creating across a note what
exactly what information are you
providing in your ad copy
whether it's a banner ad or whether it's
a text ad
the kind of content which is going to be
there in the ad that has to be in line
with
for the end customers really like
plus uh the other thing is
that you are promoting it across with
the help of right set of keywords for
the pair ads for the paid ads this is
another one and also the other set of
points is and hope is to measure across
the performance on regular basis
so that you can keep a track of what's
going on
where things are going wrong and where
things are not
and then you can take across actions
accordingly
all right so nook says for example i do
similar for financial planning right so
having a measurability impact that's one
plus also making sure your ad has
got the same language which your end
audience like to
uh read across and also make sure that
you're
targeting
reaching out to those set of people who
will who are a good fit for your seminar
they should get across
they should get across the communication
for sure
that's what the marketing
is all about it has to be
laser targeted and so forth
all right so thank you so much guys for
being part of the session today
really appreciate you guys for joining
in and listening to me for the past an
hour
it's been
a great session uh just because you guys
did interact quite a lot
i i
do want to say thanks to each one of you
and we'll keep meeting for other
webinars and we keep also
meaning for other trainings and so forth
feel free to uh
feel free to inquire about our other
courses the digital marketing course
and
really more than happy to give you
across the answer to answer to your
questions across
thank you so much take care and
have a good day or have a good night
depends on whatever time zone you guys
are thank you and open thank you for me
bye-bye bye for now
you